The value proposition for a company that's selling services is kind of the same.
You just need to ask--what are core services that are part of your value proposition.
Consulting, a haircut, investment advice, and if you're selling whether it's software or hardware,
you could have separate services that are part of this whole product--
pre- and post-sales services, finding the right solution, financing, free delivery.
Amazon makes a great business because in fact they could do 1-day delivery
or they could do 2-day Premier Service.
That is--service is sometimes, well, might seem to be ??? or kind of add ons
actually making your products work better than the competitors.
And then what are after-sales services--free maintenance, disposal, etc.
And so all these add up again to what is it that your product features do.